in the 1970s and 80s over 100 families
in California had the homes ransacked
by the same man many of them woke up in
the middle of the night to a flash light
blinding their eyes a man was standing
over their bed wearing a black ski mask
he held knives to their throats and guns
to their heads demanding that they do
what he said if they wanted to live
within a matter of hours he ruined and
ended lives slipping small mementos into
his pocket as he ran into the darkness
51 women were raped in their own beds
sometimes while their husbands and
children watched he murdered 12 people
that we know of that the kill counts may
be higher he traveled throughout
California targeting homes wherever he
went
he changed his style of killing and left
misleading clues to throw off the police
unlike most serial killers there was no
connection between the victims and
virtually no way of predicting where he
would strike next
the survivors tried to move on with
their lives but many of them received
phone calls years after the attacks
hearing a threatening whisper on the
other line remember when we played in
1986 the killings mysteriously stopped
in the trail it just ran cold for
decades the serial killer was on the
loose the police called him the east
area rater store the ear for short he
has also been called the original Night
Stalker for years the true identity of
the ear was an unsolved a mystery that
no one in California could forget for 44
years straight the Sacramento County
Police Department received phone calls
from people who believed that they had
information about the ear and yet none
of those suspects ever panned out a
freelance writer name's Michelle
McNamara began digging into this cold
case in 2006 she began a blog and a
podcast called true crime diary and
shared clues with a community of online
web sleuths who were equally as
passionate about getting the ear behind
bars in 2013 she wrote an article about
the east area rapist in Los Angeles
Magazine called
in the footsteps of a killer she gave
this murderer a more fitting nickname
the Golden State killer she began
writing a book called I'll be gone in
the dark where she interviewed detective
compiled information across various
jurisdictions that had never been pieced
together before she met an investigator
from the Contra Costa County Police
Department named pool halls and together
they shared theories and information on
how to potentially catch the killer
in 2016 Michelle McNamara suddenly
passed away in her sleep but before she
died she told her husband that the one
thing she wanted was for the Golden
State killer to get caught it didn't
matter to her if she was the one to do
it after taking time to grieve her
husband patton oswalt hired helped her
posthumously published her book it was
finished in February of 2018 one of the
many leads pool halls discussed with
McNamara before she died was the
potential of DNA evidence found on new
genealogy websites like 23andme
Hall's took the DNA from old rape kits
and ran it through an online genealogy
database and while they got a match to a
first cousin together with a task force
they were able to gather enough evidence
to find the man who matched the DNA in
April of 2018 the police raided the home
of Joseph James - Angela
[Music]
while we do not know the intimate
details about his private life it would
seem that Joseph James de Angelo had a
fairly normal childhood he was born in
1945 in bath New York his father also
named Joseph de Angelo was a celebrated
pilot in the Air Force during World War
two his mother Kathleen grote was a
waitress at a Denny's his parents would
later divorce
Kathleen married her second husband and
they moved out to California
there was a piece of paper found at one
of the crime scenes that may give some
insight into his childhood the paper had
been named the homework evidence and it
reads like a journal entry Matt is the
world the world that reminds me of the
sixth grade I hated that year D'Angelo
goes on to write about his teacher who
punished him for talking in class by
forcing him to write the same sentence
50 to 150 times as a homework assignment
I never hated anyone as much as I hated
him he describes spending hours on this
homework and wrote it wasn't fair to
make me suffer like that I cried because
I was ashamed I will be ashamed of my
sixth grade yeah forever some people
believe that the story of the sixth
grade may have been a lie it could have
been a red herring to confuse the police
about his motives for a crime or it
could be that he truly does see himself
as a victim and he sees the sixth grade
as the turning point in his life when he
began to harbor a deep hatred for people
he attended Folsom High School in
Sacramento and then California State
University in Sacramento to earn a
degree in criminal justice he joins the
Navy after graduation and he served in
the Vietnam War in the late 60s he was
engaged to young women named Bonnie Cole
well who worked as a lab assistant at
Sierra College Bonnie called off the
engagement since it broke tangelos heart
we may never know what happens behind
closed doors but according to her
brother she had plenty of good reasons
for dumping him just like the shame and
anger he harbored towards the sixth
grade teacher he'd never let go of this
betrayal years later victims would hear
him sobbing I hate you Bonnie I hate you
Bonnie over and
again in 1973 Joseph trans to Angela
married a woman named Sharon Marie
huddle and they would go on to have
three daughters together in 1974 he
graduated from the police academy and
became an officer in Visalia California
the very next year in 1975 a police
officer was shot by a criminal known for
years as the Visalia ran soccer who has
now been identified as Joseph James
Angelo in 1976 he transferred to the
Auburn Police Department he was caught
stealing a can of dog repellents and a
hammer from a grocery store these items
clearly should have been a red flag that
he was up to more than shoplifting but
the police fired him and they didn't
look into it any further after being
fired from his job D'Angelo threatened
to kill all the police chief Nick will
ik a few days after being threatened the
police chief's daughter ran into his
room in the middle of the night saying
that she saw a man in a mask outside
shining a flashlight into her bedroom
when the chief went outside to check he
saw shoe impressions at his daughter's
window
first recorded victim was a ransacking
in Visalia California in 1974 after
D'Angelo joined the police force in the
beginning he was sloppy he didn't wear a
mask and witnesses were able to describe
his face to the police he was 29 years
old at the time but he looked young for
his age many people believe the ran Saco
was in his teens or his early 20s but he
would not begin to kill people until it
was in his 30s
according to crime writer Billy Jensen
he has spoken to victims who believed
Joseph James to Angelo
attempted to murder them long before
1974 and as the police uncover new
evidence about him it may reveal in much
darker youth back in the 1970's and 80's
various police jurisdictions did not
communicate with one another when it
came to their crimes
D'Angelo would have known this fact
firsthand and he took advantage of this
after committing a few crimes in one
County he would simply move on to the
next one after nearly being caught as a
ransack he went to great lengths to
prevent the young scene and began
wearing a black ski mask he also planned
out strategies for each of his crimes
police sketches and physical
descriptions were released they looked
almost identical to his true face so he
lost a huge amount of weight in order to
change his appearance he targeted
one-story homes with similar layouts
which made it easier for him to tell how
many people were in the house he drove
around neighborhoods and sketched out
maps to help him find his way at night
after breaking into someone's house he
would search through the victims persons
look for her driver's license when he
approached them in their bedrooms he
would whisper their names which made
them wonder if he actually knew them in
their personal lives he would also take
notice of their hobbies and make up a
story of where he knew them from people
know now that he chose his victims at
random and he was purposefully leaving
false breadcrumbs for them to follow for
example one married couple has a boat in
their driveway so he said I saw you at
the lake other times he would give the
victims false information about himself
like don't tell the pigs about my van
outside he didn't have a van in fact his
transportation of choice was bicycles
that he would steal from open garages
and later dump as he ran this way no one
could identify his real vehicle and
reported to the police but the fact that
he always calls police officers pigs was
also misleading since he was a cop
himself after years of targeting women
who were home alone he rose the stakes
higher and we've gone to couples he
would come prepared with pre-tied
shoelaces so he could force the husband
to lay on his stomach and tie his hands
and then put a stack of plates on the
man's back if the husband moved he said
he would hear the crashing plates and he
would kill the wife immediately the
husband has a laborer
helpless while he heard his wife being
sexually assaulted D'Angela switched up
the weapons he used in each break-in
sometimes it was a knife sometimes it
was a gun in one case he even beat
someone to death with a log from the
fireplace the only common threat he
could not run away from was his own body
each of his rape victims described him
as having an extremely small penis this
would become a detail that investigators
would take very seriously
they asked local doctors if they could
identify patients with a micropenis and
ruled out potential suspects if they
were too well-endowed
he was a psychological sadist who got
off on instilling fear into the hearts
of human beings one of the many tricks
he used to avoid CAPTCHA was waiting in
their house long after committing the
rape one victim in Sacramento laid in
her bed after being assaulted for
several minutes her young daughter had
been laying in bed next to her the
entire time and when the mother asked
her daughter if she was okay
the little girl whispered mommy he was
still standing in the bedroom hiding in
the darkness as soon as she spoke he
moved forward and pushed down on the bed
next to her head he would then leave
silently while his victims remained
frozen on the bed in fear this gave him
hours to escape before the police were
called months or even years after being
raped Angelo would call his victims to
taunt them on Christmas Day threatening
to come back and finish the job
any of his surviving victims today PTSD
according to Carol daily women who
worked with Sacramento County Police
Department in the 1970s they held a
town-hall meeting to discuss the east
area rapist people were understandably
terrified this was years before proper
security systems were invented over 6000
guns were sold in a month people were
hiring locksmiths to
deadbolts to their doors and many people
bought guard dogs to keep them safe
during the town hall meetings to discuss
that year a man stood up in the crowd
and claims that he did not believe that
the ear was real because he could not
fathom that any man would allow his wife
to be raped while he was home a few
months later that same man and his wife
became victims officer Carol Daley was
shaken to the core
she knew that whoever the year was he
had been at the meeting that night
probably relishing in the fear that he
brought to those people the devil was
hiding in plain sight since he could no
longer work as a police officer Joseph
D'Angelo became a big rig truck mechanic
for a grocery chain called Save Mart
according to one of his co-workers
D'Angelo was always on his best behavior
and acted like he was afraid of getting
in trouble
he was never late to work he never
called in sick secretly he continued his
crimes at night only stopping in the
year 1986 no one knows yet why he chose
that year to stop his killing spree
except that it was the same year that
his youngest daughter was born it's
possible that he reached a point where
he simply could no longer continue to
live a double life and keep it secret
from his family or perhaps he continued
his crimes under a completely different
mo at home he had a reputation for being
an angry and violent man
people in the neighborhood avoided
interacting with him and he never made
any friends he once left his neighbors a
voicemail threatening to kill their
entire family the father recognized
Angelo's voice and knocked on his door
to confront him Angela responded that he
left the voicemail because that dog was
barking too much his neighbors would
often hear Joseph D'Angelo screaming and
cursing at his wife and daughters so
loudly that they could hear him inside
their house he didn't seem to care what
people thought of them because he
frequently stood in his front yard
screaming at himself he would yell I'll
kill you
even though no one was there meanwhile
Sacramento County investigator Paul
holes had been hunting the Golden State
killer for 24 years
holls was getting ready to retire but he
was still obsessed
with solving the case he was finally
able to get a DNA ancestry company to
agree to work with him and uploaded the
DNA from the Golden State Killer into an
online database in January of 2018
through this technology he was able to
find a third cousin holes took this to a
Sacramento County DA and he assigned a
task force to scour this family tree
before this moment Joseph D'Angelo had
never been one of the potential suspects
he had succeeded in hiding his crimes
for 44 years the day before he was
supposed to hand in his gun and badge
pull holes sat outside of Joseph James
to Angelo's house at this point he was
so jaded by the number of failed leads
over the years that he didn't actually
expect D'Angelo to be the one holes
wondered if he should just knock on
Angelo's door and ask for a DNA sample
so they could rule him out as a suspect
but something in his gut told him to
keep on driving DNA samples they take
time to process and if he truly was the
Golden State killer he would have too
much time to run or possibly commit
suicide the police followed Angelo in
public places instead they retrieved his
DNA and fingerprints by wiping his car
door and went through its trash to find
a discarded tissue the Sacramento Crime
Lab and task force worked non-stop to
connect the dots and prove without a
doubt that he was the Golden State
killer the police obtained a search
warrant to go into Joseph's James to
Angelo's home and arrest him D'Angela he
was shocked police on the scene said
they could see it in his eyes that he
was calculating a way to escape but the
officers detained him before he had a
chance he didn't try to deny being the
Golden State killer he simply said there
is a roast in the oven since then he has
not spoken a word to the police and
refuses to give any interviews to avoid
incriminating himself since then he just
stares into space when he appears in
court
D'Angelo's wife Sharon huddle moved away
and stopped sneaking 10 decades ago at
the time of his arrest he was living
with one of his adult daughters and his
granddaughter his wife is a divorced
liar and yet she never filed for divorce
after being separated for so many years
this has led some people to speculate
that he may have threatened her or that
she may know something about his crimes
as his wife she will not be forced to
testify against him in a court of law
and this
possibly save her from being partially
responsible for his crimes Jaron huddle
released a statement basically asking
the press to leave her alone my thoughts
and prayers are for the victims and
their families
the press has relentlessly pursued
interviews of me I will not be giving
any interviews for the foreseeable
future
I ask the press to please respect my
privacy and that of my children
according to neighbors D'Angelo is
physically fit as if he was only 50
years old instead of 72 yet a stationary
bike in the house rode a motorcycle and
was walking around without any issue
however when his lawyers rolled up to
the trial he was sitting in a wheelchair
pretending to be a feeble old man who
didn't know what was going on this was
his final attempt of self-preservation
but he wasn't fooling anyone during the
motion hearings Angelo was no longer in
a wheelchair he was standing inside of a
BART holding cell next to an armed guard
he stared at the judge the entire time
with a blank expression
he showed absolutely no emotion and no
remorse it will be years before he goes
to trial but not even his defense lawyer
is trying to deny that he is the Golden
State killer there is also an ongoing
investigation with information that is
being kept from the public the police
took a lot of his personal belongings
from his home into evidence which
included many of the mementos that he
stole from his victims in maybe years
before he learned any more details about
his life or what drove him to become the
devil incarnate at the very least though
D'Angelo is finally behind bars
hopefully the victims and their families
can finally get a good night's sleep so
I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a like below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got videos like this
also more uplifting ones from people
from history who weren't terribly evil
so subscribe to find out more about
those and like I said give us a like and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]